so I was listening to radio for the
other day in the car after I dropped my
wife at work because apparently now I'm
gonna be a dad I've become really really
old and whilst I did I had an epiphany
or a polyphony so I heard on this
program that the human voice is the most
complex sound in nature and actually the
muscles that you use in the chest whilst
exhaling in order to speak are capable
of the same kind of refined movement and
dexterity as the human hand and it's
something that can be trained and most
of us don't train our voices and say
we're only capable of regular speech but
if you focus on this and if you take
conscious effort to see what your voice
is capable of well then you can do stuff
like this so that was beardyman a
beatboxer and comedian who is fascinated
by getting the very most possible out of
his voice and creating sounds that no
one else can create I was constantly
trying to extend my repertoire of noises
to be the very maximum that it could be
I was constantly experimenting with
these noises and what this made me
really think about was the fact that
there's just so much about a human body
so much that we're capable of that we
just don't train there's so much
untapped potential and it's not just
these kinds of abstract and strange
skills like beatboxing but also things
that can affect our performance and our
physical strength and our speed and our
fitness and health things that we just
overlook because we haven't really
thought about it that if we were to put
more focus on more emphasis on then we'd
be able to see incredible benefits and
so in this video I'm going to share some
of the most interesting options for
increasing your strength and performance
that you might not have considered and
that many people overlooked
so to kick things off I'm going to start
with something that a lot of us do know
about but we still don't necessarily
incorporate into our training that's
grip strength this is a perfect example
of something that could improve your
performance incredibly and also your
general health if you were to
incorporate it into your training
problem is a lot of people assume that
their grip is getting trained when
they're lifting weights generally so
they don't need to spend specific time
training that area and at the same time
they find it kind of boring this isn't
one of those mirror muscles but actually
training your grip has all kinds of
incredible benefits not only is it
important for a whole range of sports as
well as martial arts and self-defense
for gripping onto things as well as
climbing and parkour but it can also
increase your strength by improving the
grip that you have on the thing you're
lifting so you're wasting less energy
holding on to it and you can therefore
focus more of your neural drive on
pushing it or pulling it and generally
moving it around I've made a whole video
on grip finger and forearm training so
I'm not gonna go into it now but just a
few things that you can start doing
right away to make sure no longer
missing out on this is to a just make
sure you're using those exercises that
also do target the grip in a big way so
that means heavy deadlifts that means
things like weighted pull-ups and hangs
at the same time you can do some things
to increase the focus slightly on the
grip so that might mean using a wider
barbell when you're curling so you've
got to grip onto it harder it might mean
removing the attachment on the cable
pull down on the cable pulleys just so
you're pulling the actual cable itself
you can also use specific examples of
grip training that means things like
rope climbing it means things like
finger board pull-ups
build up to that otherwise you can cause
damage to your tendons and your fingers
at the same time you can use things like
grip trainers finger push-ups check out
the video and start incorporating grip
strength into the rest of your training
and see the results across all your
lifts and all your performance ok so
something that I haven't talked about on
this channel much before and something
that you should definitely consider
looking into is straight arm strength so
straight arm strength of course is your
strength with your arms straight most of
the movements that we focus on in the
gym if we're not gymnasts involve having
our arms bent or bending around to
building our bent arm strength
doesn't have that much carryover to
straight arm strength and straight arm
strength whilst it might not look
exciting because you're not moving
something is incredibly important for a
range of other things in particular it's
incredibly important if you want to
build your ability to perform
calisthenics skills so for instance the
planche or the front lever it also give
you more stability through a whole range
of other movements whether that's the
bench press whether that's push ups or
press ups I say press ups by the way
because I'm British and also it's a
bench presses and it's not a bench push
but anyways building that straight arm
strength will give you more stability
that you can translate to a whole bunch
of other things at the same time also
trains the ligaments around the elbows
and there's not really tons of other
ways to train this and if you don't then
it can cause injury and especially if
you're moving up towards something like
the Iron Cross you really need straight
arm strength to be able to do stuff like
that and of course it has carry over and
I just hate the idea of being this
really ripped strong athlete or body
builder who has an entire aspect of
their strength like straight arm
strength missing of course straight arm
strength is crucial for a whole bunch of
gymnastics movements and many people
will say that gymnasts are pound for
pound some of the strongest athletes on
the planet so we can all stand to learn
from them how much of the musculature in
the upper arms biceps specifically comes
from straight arm work versus some form
of bent arm work the majority of the
massive biceps they see is gonna come
from the straight arm work nothing put
better mass on a bicep secondary from
the ring strength then high-volume rope
climbs so I'm gonna do a video on this
in future I'm gonna look into it in a
lot more depth I've only just started
incorporating it properly into my own
training but here are some things that
you can start doing right away first of
all obviously you can start training for
those straight arm skills that I've been
talking about such as the planche and
ways you can do this include getting
into the upper position in the press ups
press ups and then leaning forwards with
your arms straight so that you're taking
more weight onto your arms at the same
time you can also practice doing things
like crow pose or frog stand just making
sure to keep your hair arms are locked
out as you do just hold that position
you can also do a bunch of other
exercises balanced specifically aimed at
building your straight
strengths but just make them also
benefit straight arm strength so for
instance if you're gonna do leg raises
why not do them on the dip bars and then
keep your arms locked out you should
feel the tension in the elbows as you're
doing it and that way you're getting
double benefit you're training your abs
and you're training your straight arm
strength you can also do a bunch of
hanging tight movements to train
straight arm strength that includes
pangs which also improve your shoulder
range of motion they improve they
decompress your spine and this is
something that we might have seen
they're great for grip strength and this
is something that we might have seen our
ancestors doing again because well if
you look at great apes they spend a lot
of time just hanging from branches dead
hands are actually really good for whole
bunch of stuff I'm gonna come back to
them soon so try incorporating those you
can use things like body weight shrugs
in order to shrug dips in order to build
the lower traps and at the same time you
can focus on the muscle specifically
training the forearms will improve your
straight arm strength because they help
to brace the elbow in particular the
brachialis which can also train with
hammer curls and at the same time
anything that trains the shoulder girdle
the serratus muscles is also going to
benefit that oh and ring push-ups ring
dips RT o push-ups rings turned out
where you're turning your arms rings in
general are really good for building
stability and that straight arm strength
when you're on the Rings we need the
grip turned out past parallel now back
in the day Greg Glassman and I'm Greg as
the you know he's a super bright guy
founder a CrossFit but he just didn't
understand why we would turn the Rings
past parallel he thought it was just
aesthetics coach it's just aesthetics
got it turned past parallel so that the
brachialis is activated all right
there's a reason that after all these
years of CrossFit being on reigns and
doing thousands upon thousands of
kipping pull-ups and dips and all this
stuff that there are no iron crosses
unless they were previous gymnasts right
there's no homegrown crossfitter has an
iron cross something that somewhat
protected straight arm strength is the
hollow body so this is a position where
you're bracing your upper body and your
core in a similar manner to the arms
during moves like the planche and it
will greatly help you to improve your
control your balance and to get those
awesome
calisthenics skills basically it
involves contracting the upper body in
the core and the abs in such a way that
way to lie on the floor your small of
your back would be touching the ground
rather than raised from it and if you
get this right then in the push-up
position you should feel as though if
the roof was to collapse on your back
you'd be able just hold it up it's this
rigid rock-solid position there's
perfect for preventing injury and for
plugging all those holes in the kinetic
chain for being one strong rigid
cohesive unit
another more simple one is work capacity
work capacity is basically cardio
fitness but in the context of whatever
form of exercise it is you're interested
in doing this is one of the main things
that is targeted in CrossFit where the
aim is to be able to do lots of
different deadlifts in a row lots and
lots of pull-ups and then a run to be
able to not just exert your strength
once but to be able to do it repeatedly
without seeing flaws in your performance
and your technique that ultimately leads
to injury but this is important for
everyone because as you know if you've
ever done lots of pull-ups if you're
capable of doing lots of pull-ups often
the reason you have to stop is not
because your muscles fatigued but
because you're exhausted and you start
to feel a bit sick as a result the same
can happen in any kind of compound
movement so you need to build that to
cardio base in order to be able to
perform your best no matter what you're
doing this even translates to
productivity and focus a lot of people
want to get more Envy in their daily
life they don't think about running and
generally improving their ability to
exert energy
over a long time running and doing
various cardio forms of exercise is the
best way to improve your performance in
pretty much anything you're doing
because you've just got more energy and
you're more efficient that's using that
energy a lot of body builders and people
don't want to use cardio because they're
afraid it's gonna cause them to lose
their muscle or they find it boring
there are fun ways you can train I
deliver your metcon that you can look at
and at the same time I've done a video
on why bodybuilders should train their
cardio because actually make some more
anabolic by lowering your heart rate you
actually are in a more anabolic state
more of the time there's lots of reasons
to be doing cardio and this is why you
often see power lifters who are training
in a certain specificity who are
training for a particular goal using
cardio and other forms of training under
the umbrella term general physical
preparedness this basically means that
they understand that in order to perform
their best in their specific skill they
need a general level of fitness
well you can't be great at powerlifting
if you have no cardio endurance so make
sure you're running or doing HIIT or
some kind of cardio even if that isn't
what you're interested in getting better
at specifically so this is just a few
examples of different training methods
and concepts from different sports
fields activities practices you can
incorporate into your training to see
massive performance improvements both in
the gym and in your life of course I
haven't covered everything here there's
lots more that we tend to overlook and I
couldn't possibly cover everything but I
am going to cover more this is going to
become a part one of two video because
it's gonna get insanely long otherwise
so I'm gonna come back next time I'm
going to launch straight into it and
I'll see you then